الحمله هاي من عشائر دير الزور الى
اخواننا بالحسكه واهلنا بالحسكه الحمله
مثل يا اخوان لكن ما ازعل علينا نشوف
اخواننا عطشانين واحنا شبعانين
نرويهم هذا اللي قدرنا عليه
[موسيقى]
نحن نجد الدول والناشده المجتمع الدولي
انه احنا بمحافظه الحسكه اقسم بالله هي
حاله يرثى لها عطشانين نريد فزعه نريد
نريد كل شيء والله العالم بي ناس تقدر
بيناس ما تقدر على حق المي لكن نشكركم مو
كثيره على هالديره الزور
[موسيقى]
اطمنكم وابشركم انه احنا موجودين
وان شاء الله بعون الله تعالى راح نستهدف
الاحياء في جميع محافظه الحسكه ان الله عز
وجل ابغى ناحيه وبدي انا راح نوزعه وبدي
انا راح نعبي البراميل ونعبي خزانات المي
[موسيقى]
75% من شعيطاتنا الخطير
75% ما يصلهم مي وحافرين لكن تلبيه
للنقائكم
وتعاليم ديننا وتعاليم سيدنا محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم
راح نشكل
ومساعده ونجيكم بعون الله تعالى
[موسيقى]